amerikanische wissenschaftler haben zum
ersten mal überhaupt starke hinweise auf
gravitationswellen gemessen
wenn sich die daten reproduzieren lassen
würden sie damit albert einsteins 1918
postulierte allgemeine
relativitätstheorie zu einem großen teil
bestätigen und vielleicht sogar einen
komplett neuen wissenschaftlichen
forschungsbereiche öffnen
es könnte die größte wissenschaftliche
entdeckung der letzten paar jahrzehnte
sein und ist jetzt schon ein favorit für
einen nobelpreis aber was sind
gravitationswellen eigentlich genau und
wie funktionieren sie
einsteins theorie geht so gravitation
die kraft die uns mit den füßen auf der
erde und unsere erde in der umlaufbahn
der sonne hält ist eigentlich nur eine
verkrümmung der raumzeit unserer
vierdimensionalen welt diese verkrümmung
wird oft durch ein zweidimensionales
netz dargestellt dass von einem körper
mit masse durchgedrückt wird große
objekte wie die sonne oder schwarze
löcher erzeugen auch größere dellen und
andere objekte werden deswegen in ihre
richtung abgelenkt ein teil der theorie
besagt auch dass alles was ich mit masse
durch den raum bewegt also sterne
schwarze löcher sogar du und ich und die
apfel hier wellen erzeugt
gravitationswellen das sind
veränderungen in der raumzeit die sich
vom objekt weg bewegen je massereicher
des objektes und je schneller es sich
bewegt desto größer sollen auch die
gravitationswellen seien dies aus sendet
diese wellen denen und stauchen die
raumzeit überall da wo sie hindurch
fliegen
nur leider gibt es auch ein kleines
problem wenn es darum geht diese wellen
auch zu messen denn sie sind winzig ihr
effekt auf uns ist minimal
wenn wir menschen uns mit unserer masse
bewegen dann sind wir quasi keine
gravitationswellen aus denn wir haben ja
auch im vergleich zu den großen dingen
des universums kaum masse aber es gibt
dinge in unserem universum die so starke
gravitationswellen aussenden dass wir
sind hier auf der erde messen können zum
beispiel schwarze löcher die
amerikanischen wissenschaftler haben
sich jetzt ein astronomisches und
seltenes ereignis zu nutze gemacht dass
in circa 13 milliarden lichtjahren
entfernung stadt fahren dort
fusionierten zwei schwarze löcher mit
der masse von 60 tonnen auf spektakuläre
art und weise zuerst und greifen sich
die beiden schwarzen löcher nur langsam
doch je näher sie sich kam desto größer
wurde auch ihre geschwindigkeit in der
spitze erreichten sie bis zu 0 15
also die hälfte der lichtgeschwindigkeit
bis sie dann schließlich in einem
massiven schwarzen loch fusionierten
die astronomisch große masse und die
hohe geschwindigkeit der beiden
schwarzen löcher sorgt in der theorie
auch für extrem starke
gravitationswellen die wie hier auf der
erde sogar messen können also hat eine
vereinigung von wissenschaftlern mit dem
namen laser interferometer gravitation
repository versucht diese wellen zu
messen den testanlagen mit laser
interferometer die geformt sind wie ein
riesiges l wurde der versuch
durchgeführt
in jedem dieser arme gibt es ein 25
kilometer langer tunnel mit einem
spiegel am ende in der mitte wird ein
laserstrahl ausgesendet der über einheit
durchlässigen spiegel in beide tunnel
geschickt wird
weil ein tunnel parallel und der andere
senkrecht zu den gravitationswellen
steht soll ein zeitlicher unterschied
gemessen werden der tunnel der senkrecht
zu den gravitationsfeld gebaut wurde
wird von diesem gestaucht und gedehnt
und so entsteht eine zeitliche differenz
zwischen den beiden signalen die man
messen kann
und aus dieser zeitlichen differenz
lässt sich errechnen wie stark die
gravitationswellen sind und das ist
teilweise echt wenig auf die länge eines
zweieinhalb kilometer langen tunnels
verändert sich der raum um ein
zehntausendstel der größe eines protons
das ist winzig aber die wissenschaftler
derlei können das messen und wenn man
mehrere testanlagen miteinander
verbindet kann man sogar brecht und aus
welcher richtung die wellen genau kommen
all das klingt ziemlich cool
zugegebenermaßen aber in den letzten 100
jahren seit einsteins allgemeiner
relativitätstheorie wurde schon mehrmals
behauptet dass gravitationswellen
gemessen wurden und wir erst mal konnten
die ergebnisse nicht reproduziert werden
oder es haben sich fehler eingeschlichen
die lego wissenschaftler selber und auch
viele andere experten sind sich aber
extrem sicher dass es sich nicht um
einen messfehler handeln kann
denn die geräte sind extrem genau
nachdem sie die letzten fünf jahre
updated und erneuert wurden die
wissenschaftler können zum beispiel
feststellen ob in ein paar kilometern
entfernung gerade ein auto fährt nur
durch die erschütterungen im boden und
es gibt sogar drei mitarbeiter deren
einziger job es ist die messungen zu
sabotieren und fehler einzubauen
in diesem fall sollen die ergebnisse
aber echt seien und fehlerquellen wurden
akribisch vermieden
falls andere wissenschaftler das
ergebnis bestätigen und reproduzieren
können dann eröffnet sich ein neuer
wissenschaftlicher sachbereich eine neue
möglichkeit unser universum zu
beobachten
leider ist die erde als standort für die
messung von gravitationswellen nicht
besonders optimal denn es gibt viele
erschütterungen im boden die die
messungen erschweren aber vielleicht
kann man in zukunft die messungen von
gravitationswellen ins weltall bringen
denn die welt an hat man kein problem
mit erschütterungen mit tausenden
kilometern entfernung zwischen mehreren
satelliten die sich mit laser anpeilen
könnte man auch viel größere wellen
frequenzen wahrnehmen
bis jetzt konnten wir unser universum
mit licht radiowellen und gammastrahlen
wahrnehmen aber mit ein bisschen glück
eröffnet uns gravitationswellen bald
eine vollkommen neue sicht auf unser
universum und erschließen uns neue
erkenntnisse über die regeln gesetze und
vielleicht sogar den ursprung unseres
universums
wir leben schon im extrem spannenden
zeiten leute bleibt neugierig ich bin
weg bringen